I think the duty of maturity is to
recognize the difference between what is
and what ought to be and to try to
always keep your eye on both which
sounds much easier to do than it is I
think the duty of maturity is
increasingly and the older I get
actually the more important I think it
is is not to resign not to tell yourself
that being realistic means giving up
your hopes and your ideals most of the
culture tells us that the best part of
our lives are the times between oh I
don't know 16 and you know 25 anybody
who's made it over that period of time
would rarely want to live to have those
years back again they're really hard
you're figuring out who you are you're
figuring out your strengths and
weaknesses but the whole culture is
combined and telling us that that's the
best time of our lives have to think
about what the message is because
there's no empirical evidence in fact
there's a host of psychological studies
that show in the most cases people
actually get happier as they get older
so the only reason I can think of for
blasting that message is to prepare us
for the idea that we shouldn't expect
much out of life and that's a mistake
you